[Musique]
tu pas un pli verre
avec des amis à gauche
[Musique]
à son
bébé se vend c'est mon sens c'est quoi
ce mardi midi fait des brutales team
d'afflelou
ya pas seulement de la faune et à autre
chose ça débouchera chiottes
un tag onf retrait cette année à 0 duvet
mois
il faut être très prudent
regardons bien s'il n'y a pas marqué
poison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je serai grand je serai alcoolique
j'habiterai dans un formule 1
geromel
5 heures
le bronze aux jo mondiaux ou jo le
beaujolais
je sais pas pourquoi je chante ansériens
les beaux sortent comme ça aux
modulations suite
cij cdn idée n'a jamais existé
trouvant que j'en ai aidé à travers 100
puis jean philippe smet six
[Musique]
mois
deux fois plus de bonheur est deux fois
plus d'amis formés voulu visite en
indonésie
alors mais les doigts
puisqu'il connaît aux femmes rick hunter
réponse
et connaît rien j'ai attaqué quand je
vois dans la salle monde en hiver le
pinard c'est pas interdit que j'essaie
mais non non ferreux et non ferreux
génèse oui l alcool la gauche est la
solution de tous nos problèmes dans la
vie